how is it to return to the ballroom
tonight it was awesome I love my bet my
my Dancing with the Stars family I mean
I had I had so much fun with the
experience so anytime I just get to say
hi to friends I mean supporting shows
great and you know I mean I do sit-ups
for a reason something you guys all
shirtless you had a lot of people jaws
open does that ever get old to you which
part beats shirtless and the chairs and
the women yes I mean I feel like I'm
objectified it's like you know there's
more to me than just chiseled ABS we'd
be a nice sneak peek of Colton's season
tonight have you spoken to Colton at all
we know that I have not are they done
filming you know more than I do have you
heard any rumblings about how his season
went I really have no I remember I
really I didn't even know they were done
wrapping I don't ask these questions you
know there's a poster that came out a
couple days ago do you feel like they're
going too far with the whole virginity
of it all I personally am NOT interested
in whether Colton loses his virginity or
not I am interested in whether he meets
someone he has feelings for are you
gonna find someone that you have
feelings for such a great question
I haven't I've been working really hard
on others things and I started in a
central line so there's that there's
that but no no lucky lady well hopefully
she'll feel lucky I don't know you make
of Kaitlyn and Shawn breaking out I
don't you know they had a good long run
I truly haven't kept in touch mom so I
really don't know anything about
anything
I like anyone who goes through a breakup
I'm sure it's hard and I wish anyone who
goes through breakup all the best as I
would then there's rumors that Vanessa
and Peter have been hanging out talking
I mean I don't again I heard it here
heard it from you first
if that's true good congratulations
that's fantastic I mean III would love
her to be happy and if that makes her
happy then I'm all for it
what are you doing for Thanksgiving
what're your plans I leave tomorrow to
go home visit the family for a few
the loved ones and eat some turkey
watching football
[Music]
[Applause]